Élue par les internautes à trois reprises,
et cette année encore, « plus belle gare de
France », inscrite à l’inventaire des Monuments
Historiques depuis 1975, la gare de Metz est un
bâtiment hors du commun. Symbole des rivalités
franco-allemandes pendant un demi-siècle,
elle porte les traces de cette histoire
tragique, et pas seulement parce qu’elle
est le lieu officiel de la mort de Jean Moulin
en 1943, lors de son transfert pour l’Allemagne.
A l’occasion des Journées du Patrimoine 2021
ce week-end du 18 et 19 septembre, la SNCF vous
ouvre les portes du salon d’honneur de la gare et
des recoins habituellement inaccessibles. C’est
l’occasion de découvrir son histoire.
Le gouvernement parisien tergiverse depuis
les années 1830 pour la création d’une ligne
de chemin de fer à destination de l’Est. Dans
cette optique, chaque ville milite pour faire
passer le train par chez elle. Les crédits de la
ligne Paris-Strasbourg sont votés en 1842 sous
la monarchie de Juillet, mais il n’y a au départ,
pas de liaison prévue à destination de Metz. Une
voie pour relier Metz à Nancy est construite en
1850 et la ville se dote d’une gare provisoire,
un embarcadère en bois aménagé à l’extérieur des
remparts. Une nouvelle porte y est d’ailleurs
percée pour accéder à la gare, et elle est nommée
porte Serpenoise. Elle est toujours visible
aujourd’hui c’est désormais un arc de triomphe,
forme que lui ont donné les Allemands. Le premier
trajet au départ de Metz a lieu le 10 juillet 1850
et la gare permanente n’est mise en service qu’en
avril 1853. Il s’agit d’une gare-terminus, qui
n’a que deux voies à destination du sud. Pour
rejoindre le nord, Thionville et le Luxembourg
par exemple, on repart aussi vers le sud,
pour trouver un embranchement. Cette première
gare de Metz n’est plus visible dans le paysage,
puisqu’elle a disparu dans un incendie en 1872.
Lorsqu’éclate la guerre avec la Prusse en 1870,
l’Est de la France voit se diriger de nombreux
trains vers l’Est, mais dans un désordre total.
Les soldats manquent, les wagons ne sont pas
déchargés… Le terminus de Metz voit se constituer
un immense embouteillage ferroviaire. La ville
de Metz, assiégée à partir du 19 août 1870,
avec 150 000 soldats à l’intérieur des murs,
finit par se rendre tout comme la ville de
Paris quelques mois plus tard. La guerre est
perdue et l’Alsace-Moselle est annexée à ce qui
est devenu entre-temps l’empire Allemand. La ville
de Metz est donc intégrée au territoire allemand,
dans le land d’Alsace-Lorraine, et la frontière
passe désormais à dix kilomètres de la ville.
Le Reich envisage immédiatement la construction d’une grandegare centrale à Metz en lieu et place de la
gare française située à l’extérieur de la ville.
Puisque Metz est désormais une ville frontière,
il faut lui donner les moyens de défendre
l’empire. Dès la fin de l’année 1872,
la liaison ferroviaire entre Metz et Berlin
est actée. Les Allemands renoncent finalement
à trouver de la place dans l’enceinte des remparts
pour la nouvelle gare, et il est décidé de rebâtir
sur la gare française qui a brûlé en juillet 1872.
Les voies existent déjà et le site est libre pour
un agrandissement conséquent. Cette deuxième gare,
la première gare allemande est inaugurée en 1878,
elle est aujourd’hui appelée « ancienne
gare ». Elle a abrité pendant longtemps
des bureaux de la SNCF et doit prochainement
accueillir un centre statistique de l’INSEE.
Toutefois, cette gare ne permet pas de
réaliser les grands projets défensifs de
l’empereur Guillaume II. La France est désormais
alliée à la Russie et l’Allemagne est menacée sur
deux fronts. Le XVIe corps d’armée du Reich est
stationné dans la ville, mais il doit pouvoir être
rejoint rapidement par des renforts et recevoir du
matériel en quantité. La disposition en cul-de-sac
de la gare de Metz exige de longues manœuvres de
train. Pour y remédier, les Allemands abattent les
remparts de la ville en 1898 et un premier projet
de gare de passage est élaboré l’année d’après
pour remplacer l’existante.
L’ordonnance impériale qui décide la construction
de la nouvelle gare de Metz est signée en avril
1901 par l’empereur allemand. Ce grand projet
répond à des intérêts pratiques, stratégiques,
mais aussi symboliques. Après trente ans
d’annexion, la majorité des Lorrains reste en
effet toujours hostile à la présence allemande.
La construction d’une nouvelle gare est donc
l’occasion d’ancrer dans le paysage la domination
germanique. Le nouveau site choisi pour cette gare
qui n’est plus un terminus, mais une « gare de
passage » est 300 mètres plus à l’Est. Les travaux
de terrassement mettent au jour les fondations de
l’amphithéâtre de la colonie romaine de Divodurum,
en périphérie du chantier. Cet amphithéâtre,
l’un des plus grands de Gaule avec ses 148 par
124 mètres de diamètre, n'a malheureusement
pas conservé d’élévation puisqu’il a servi
au fil des siècles de carrière de pierre.
Quoiqu’il en soit, l’empereur Guillaume II
prend la décision d’enfouir les vestiges
pour continuer les travaux, il visite
d’ailleurs lui-même le chantier en mai 1903.
Le concours pour la réalisation de la nouvelle
gare est ouvert en décembre 1901 à tous les
architectes allemands. Le cahier des charges est
très strict et prévoit déjà beaucoup d’éléments,
circulation, salon impérial, façade lumineuse,
etc. Le jury reçoit en mai 1902 dix-neuf projets.
Le lauréat est l’architecte Jürgen Kröger,
qui doit quand même modifier son plan pour adopter
un style plus officiel, sans toutefois brusquer
les messins hostiles à la germanisation. Guillaume
II souhaite un style rappelant l’appartenance de
Metz à l’empire carolingien médiéval, un style
roman du Rhin. Kröger retouche donc à la marge
les lignes qu’il a dessinées, ajoute des voûtes
en plein-cintre, des irrégularités pittoresques et
des motifs médiévaux tirés de manuels d’histoire
de l’art : bestiaire, entrelacs stylisés et
rosace. Il s’inspire pour cela du renouveau roman
états-unien, lui-même emprunté à la France. Ironie
de l’histoire, la propagande impériale allemande
n’arrive pas à se passer de l’influence française.
La gare qui devait coûter 2 millions de marks, en
coûte finalement 29, conséquence de l’instabilité
du terrain. Le choix du site est mauvais
pour accueillir un tel bâtiment, la couche
d’argile solide est à 15 mètres de profondeur
et les ingénieurs allemands enfoncent dans le
sol plus de 3000 pieux en béton armé en guise de
fondations. Les travaux commencent finalement en
novembre 1905 et se poursuivent pendant presque
trois ans. Vitrine de l’empire, la gare est
alimentée dès sa création à l’électricité pour son
éclairage et faire fonctionner la grande horloge.
Celle-ci est installée en mai 1908 au sommet
de sa tour de 40 mètres, et elle témoigne tout
de même de l’esprit « art nouveau » que voulait à
l’origine l’architecte Kröger, puisque les heures
ne sont pas marquées par des numéros mais par des
points. L’édifice est inauguré le 17 août 1908,
en même temps que les voies qui contournent la
ville à l’est et au nord. La gare de Metz n’est
désormais plus un cul-de-sac. L’empereur Guillaume
II la visite neuf jours après l’inauguration,
c’est l’occasion pour lui de visiter le
salon construit spécialement en son honneur.
Car l’architecture intérieure est assez
remarquable. Une partie de la gare est réservée
à l’empereur et à ses hôtes de marque. On accède
à ce salon d’honneur par l’extérieur. Deux lions
en basalte gardent l’entrée. A l’intérieur,
un escalier en marbre conduit à la salle de
réception. L’entrée est aussi gardée par deux
lionnes, et il y a comme un air de Mycènes,
fouillée d’ailleurs au XIXe siècle par un
Allemand, Heinrich Schliemann. Le salon est orné
de scènes de chasse, dont l’empereur Guillaume
II raffolait. Un grand vitrail représente
l’empereur Charlemagne en majesté, conçu pour
rappeler à Metz qu’elle est depuis des siècles
intégrée à un empire germanique. Charlemagne
étant aussi revendiqué par les Français,
ce vitrail a été conservé jusqu’à nos jours,
contrairement à celui, en face, qui représentait
l’aigle impérial allemand. Ce salon est ouvert
lors des Journées du Patrimoine ce week-end du 18
et 19 septembre, alors profitez-en !
L’entrée des voyageurs se fait par la
façade principale et est aussi richement décorée.
Sur la grande voûte sont représentés dans les
entrelacs d’inspiration romane, des figures du
peuple en voyage. Divers métiers sont montrés,
musicien, militaire (francisés après
1918), bûcheron, porteur, femme à l’enfant,
etc. Au sommet, trône désormais le blason de la
Lorraine, remplaçant l’aigle impérial originel,
dont on devine encore la forme des ailes sur la
pierre. Sous la voûte, il y a quatre portraits
sculptés. Celui qui porte la plume représente
Kröger, l’architecte de la gare. Deux allégories
féminines aux extrémités de la façade représentent
les deux provinces annexées, l’Alsace à gauche,
et la Lorraine à droite. Toujours sur la façade,
des chevaux soufflant par les naseaux symbolisent
la puissance du cheval-vapeur, et d’autres reliefs
représentent les différents moyens de transports
dans l’Empire. De nombreux autres détails sont
à dénicher dans tous les recoins à l’intérieur,
éclairs pour signaler l’emplacement du
transformateur électrique, ciseaux et rasoirs pour
l’emplacement du coiffeur... Les salles d’attente
sont aussi truffées de bas-reliefs montrant les
scènes de vie de la gare, et reflètent les écarts
de richesse entre les voyageurs qui fréquentent
la première et la troisième classe. Vers la
gauche, les bâtiments de service sont ornés de
sculptures des personnels de la gare : médecin
reconnaissable à son caducée, télégraphiste
enroulé dans sa bande comme dans une écharpe,
ou encore agent de circulation fumant sa pipe.
Plusieurs salles d’attente sont prévues pour les
voyageurs, vastes et aérées, et éclairées par des
vitraux. Les voyageurs de première et deuxième
classe peuvent accéder aux buffets et restaurants
qui ont dans leurs caves, les meilleurs vins
français et les meilleures bières allemandes.
La gare compte dix quais au total, chacun
consacré à une destination, mais les indications
en langue française sont toutefois soigneusement
évitées, ce qui agace passablement les Messins.
Cette gare a en effet concentré beaucoup de
ressentiment, considérée comme prussienne,
son architecture est critiquée par beaucoup
d’habitants de la ville. Cela est bien sûr dû
à la profusion d’allégories et décors destinés à
rappeler la domination germanique. La symbolique
de la gare a d’ailleurs fait l’objet de plusieurs
travaux universitaires, dont ceux de Thomas von
Joest. Même si après 1918, les aigles impériaux
ont été remplacés par le blason de la ville,
comme sur le portail du salon d’honneur figurant
les allégories de la guerre et de l’industrie,
bon nombre de symboles allemands restent visibles.
Ce sont notamment les corniches représentant des
batailles des Germains contre les Huns ou
contre les Romains. Ces exploits antiques,
notamment menés par le chef Arminius, sont la
plus pure expression du nationalisme allemand.
Mais l’élément le plus emblématique de cette
querelle nationale dont la gare de Metz a
été l’instrument est situé au pied de la tour de
l’horloge. C’est là que le maréchal von Haeseler,
longtemps chef du corps d’armée de Metz,
reçoit sa statue. Sa tête est échangée en
1919 par les Français, et une croix de Lorraine
remplace l’aigle sur son bouclier. Mais la
victoire allemande de 1940, et la ré-annexion de
l’Alsace-Moselle au Reich allemand conduit une
nouvelle fois à modifier la statue. Les Allemands
trouvent que le chevalier français ressemble un
peu trop au maréchal Foch et le recouvrent d’une
bâche en attendant de modifier ses traits. C’est
chose faite en 1942, la statue retrouve le visage
du maréchal allemand, et la croix de Lorraine est
remplacée par le blason de la ville de Metz, que
le bouclier arbore encore aujourd’hui. Enfin,
en 1944, à la Libération de la ville, la tête
tombe à nouveau et on en sculpte une quatrième
et dernière, toujours en place aujourd’hui.
Cette gare n’est plus de nos jours détestée
par les messins, bien au contraire. La gare
arrive même régulièrement en tête des monuments
régionaux favoris de la population. Son
classement à l’inventaire des monuments
historiques et la réconciliation franco-allemande
ont fait oublier les symboles de l’impérialisme,
pour laisser apparaître toute la richesse
de son iconographie. Une superbe découverte.
Profitez de ce weekend pour visiter
ce lieu, ça vaut vraiment le coup,
vous trouverez toutes les informations dans la
barre dédiée sous la vidéo. Je remercie la SNCF
et toutes les personnes qui ont contribué à sa
réalisation et je vous donne rdv mercredi pour
un nouvel épisode ! D’ici là n’oubliez pas de
vous abonner, partager et liker et si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez soutenir la chaîne via utip
notamment le lien est juste ici. Un grand merci !